bonjour infirmières caporal-chef
chauve-souris de la 960 troisième unité
militaire département spécial du
commandement de la garde suprême
aujourd'hui je suis ici pour vous
raconter des histoires que j'ai vécu
pendant que je travaillais à l'hôpital à
pyongyang
restez avec nous incroyable destin que
celui de son bien deux mois seulement
après son arrivée à séoul
la rescapée du régime de pyongyang est
devenue chroniqueuse d'une émission de
télévision dans ce talk show les
intervenants tous nord-coréen racontent
leur passé de l'autre côté de la
frontière en décembre 2012
mon père est décédé et nous n'avions
plus d'argent j'étais dans une situation
désespérée j'ai suivi une femme et nous
avons traversé le fleuve pour aller en
chine
très vite j'ai été capturés par des
trafiquants d'organes
ils discutaient de combien coûtait un
rat j'étais terrifiée je me suis enfui
et caché pendant trois jours dans un
champ de maïs mais qui étaient engourdis
par le froid et j'ai fait mes besoins
sur moi récit poignant reconstitution et
mises en scènes larmoyantes l'émission
fascine les téléspectateurs
[Musique]
après je me suis dit tu vas survivre
avec ce programme sont guy à trouver un
travail et une certaine notoriété
aujourd'hui elle vit en couple avec son
petit ami min-soo 25 ans lui aussi vient
de corée du nord
il a fui la chine quelques mois
auparavant pour arriver à séoul
les deux ont dû franchir les mêmes
étapes
j'ai passé un mois à l'ambassade à
wengen car il faut avoir un passeport
pour prendre l'avion moi j'y suis resté
trois mois
moi c'était un mois et on était environ
15 personnes à prendre l'avion pour
venir en corée du sud
après j'ai été interrogé dans le
bâtiment des services de renseignement
pendant trois mois la première question
que m'ont posée les services secrets
c'était de savoir si j'étais réellement
nord-coréenne
ils ont voulu savoir si je n'étais pas
une espionne
ensuite je suis rentré à na wan où j'ai
reçu une formation pendant trois mois
anna one un centre ultra secret très
rarement ouvert aux médias
c'est ici que passent tous les
transfuges nord-coréens
là où se sont rencontrés sont guy
hemmings ou là où les autorités sud
coréennes ont préparé leur adaptation à
la vie capitaliste
quand on arrive on ne connaît rien de la
corée du nord tout le monde paye un
loyer gérer son argent
la langue les coutumes celui là d'un
coup tu es différentes ou du qatar
abdallah locaux autocoms donc on ne sait
pas par où commencer
et c'est inquiétant c'est pour ça qu'ils
nous enseigne la culture sud coréenne
pour que l'on puisse s'installer plus
facilement succès
après sept mois sous la surveillance des
autorités sud coréennes aujourd'hui son
mii peut enfin jouir de sa liberté en
corée du nord
je n'avais pas de chez moi comme je
n'avais pas de maison j'habitais dans
une loge de gardien à l'usiné là bas il
n'y avait ni électricité ni télévision
tout ce qu'on pouvait voir ou entendre
c'était la propagande de kim jong-un et
de kim jong il ya beaucoup supprimés ici
je mange quand je veux j'adore quand je
veux je peux aussi prendre une douche
avec de l'eau chaude
j'aime bien maintenant je suis
sincèrement contente